So today we have Nader Bensky,
he's a professor at northeastern
university working on various aspects of
computational agents that exhibit human
level intelligence.
Please give a warm welcome.
Thanks a lot.
Thanks for having me here.
So the title that was on the page was a
cognitive modeling.
I'll kind of get there,
but I wanted to put it in context.
So the bigger theme here is I want to
talk about what's called cognitive
architecture and if you've never heard
about that before,
that's great.
And I wanted to contextualize that as
how are we what,
how is that one approach to get us to
Agi and I say what my view of Agi is and
put up a whole bunch of TV and movie
characters that I grew up with that
inspire me.
That'll lead us into what is this thing
called cognitive architecture.
It's a whole research field that crosses
neuroscience,
psychology,
cognitive science,
and all the way into Ai.
So I'll try to give you kind of the
historical big picture view of it,
what some of the actual systems are out
there that might be of interest to you.
And then we'll kind of zoom in on one of
them that I've done a good amount of
work with called soar.
And what I'll try to do is tell a story,
a research story of how we started with
kind of a core research question we look
to how humans operate,
understood that phenomenon and then took
it and saw a really interesting results
from it.
And so at the end,
if this field is of interest,
there's a few pointers for you to go
read more and go experience more of
cognitive architecture.
So just rough definition of agi given us
an Agi class,
depending on the direction that you're
coming from,
it might be kind of understanding
intelligence or maybe developing a
intelligent systems that are operating
at the level of human level
intelligence,
the,
the typical differences between this and
other sorts of maybe ai machine learning
systems.
We want systems that are going to
persist for a long period of time.
Uh,
we want them robust to different
conditions.
We want them learning over time.
And here's the crux of it.
Working on different tasks and a lot of
cases,
task they didn't know were coming ahead
of time.
Uh,
I got into this because I clearly
watched too much TV and too many movies
and,
and I looked back at this and I realized
I think I'm covering seventies,
eighties,
nineties,
I guess it is.
And today,
and so this is what I wanted out of ai
and this is what I wanted to work with.
And then there's the reality that we
have today.
So instead of,
so who's watched a night writer for
instance?
Uh,
I,
I don't think that exists yet.
Uh,
but,
but maybe we're getting there and in
particular for fun,
during the Amazon Sale Day,
I got myself an Alexa and I could just
see myself at some point saying,
Hey Alexa,
please might write me an arcing script,
uh,
you know,
to,
to sync my class.
And if you have an Alexa,
you probably know the following phrase.
This,
this just always hurts me inside.
Which is.
Sorry,
I don't know that one,
which is okay.
Right?
That's a lot of people have no idea what
I'm asking,
let alone how to do that.
So what I want Alexa to respond with
after that is,
do you have time to teach me,
uh,
and to provide some sort of interface by
which back and forth we can kind of talk
through this,
uh,
that we,
we aren't there yet to say the least,
but I'll talk later about some work on a
system called Rosie that's working in
that direction.
We're starting to see,
see some ideas about being able to teach
systems how to work.
So folks who are in this field,
uh,
I think generally fall into these three
categories.
They're just curious.
They want to learn new things,
generate knowledge,
work on hard problems.
Great.
Uh,
I think there are folks who are in kind
of that mental cognitive modeling realm.
And so I'll use this term a lot.
It's really understanding how humans
think,
how humans operate human intelligence at
multiple levels.
And if you can do that one,
there's just knowledge in and of itself
of how we operate.
But there's a lot of really important
applications that you can think of if we
were able to not only understand but
predict how humans would respond,
react and various tasks.
Medicine is an easy one.
There's some work in HCI or Hri.
Uh,
I'll get to later where if you can
predict how humans would respond to it
as you can iterate tightly and develop
better interfaces.
Uh,
it's already being used in the realm of
simulation and defense industries.
Um,
I happen to fall into the latter group
which are the bottom group,
which is systems development,
which is to say just the desire to build
systems for various tasks that are
working on tasks that kind of current
ai,
machine learning can't operate on.
And I think,
uh,
when you're working at this level or on
any system that nobody's really achieved
before,
what do you,
do you,
you kind of look to the examples that
you have,
which in this case that we know of,
it's just humans,
right?
Irrespective of your motivation,
when you have kind of an intent that you
want to achieve in your research,
you kind of let that drive your
approach.
And so I often show my students this,
the turing test,
you might've heard of a or variants of
it that have come before.
These were folks who were trying to
create systems that acted in a certain
way that acted intelligently and the
kind of line that they drew,
the benchmark that they used was to say,
let's make systems that operate like
humans do.
Cognitive modelers will fit up into his
top point here to say it's not enough to
act that way,
but by some definition of thinking,
uh,
we want the system to do what humans do
or at least be able to make predictions
about it.
So that might be things like what errors
with the human make on this task,
or how long would it take them to
perform this task?
Or what emotion would be produced in
this task?
There are folks who are still thinking
about how the computer is operating,
but trying to apply a kind of rational
rules to it.
So a logician for instance,
would say if you have a and you have be
a gives you,
he gives you ca should definitely give
you see,
that's just what's rational.
And so there folks operating in that
direction and then if you go to a intro
ai class anywhere around the country,
particularly Berkeley,
because they have graphics designers
that I get to steal from,
the benchmark would be what the system
produces in terms of action and the
benchmark is some sort of optimal
rational bound irrespective of where you
work in this space.
Uh,
there,
there's kind of a common output that
arrives when you research these areas,
which is you can learn individual bits
and pieces and it can be hard to bring
them together to build a system that
either predicts or act on,
on different tasks.
So this is part of the transfer learning
problem,
but it's also part of a having distinct
theories that are hard to combine
together.
So I'm going to give an example and that
come comes out of cognitive modeling or
perhaps three examples.
So if you were in a HCI class or some
interest psychology classes,
one of the first things you'll learn
about his fits law,
which provides you the ability to
predict the difficulty level of
basically human pointing from where they
start to a particular place and it turns
out that you can learn some parameters
and model this based upon just the
distance from where you are to the
target and the size of the target.
So both moving along distance will take
awhile.
But also if you're aiming for a very
small point that can take longer than if
there's a large area that you just kinda
have to get yourself to.
And so this has held true for many
humans.
So let's say we've learned this and then
we move onto the next task and we
learned about what's called the power
law of practice,
which has been shown true in a number of
different tasks.
What I'm showing here is one of them
where you're going to draw a line
through sequential set of circles here,
starting at one,
going to two and so forth.
Not Making a mistake or at least not
trying to.
And try to do this as fast as possible.
And so for a particular person,
we would fit the AB and c parameters and
we'd see a power law.
So as you perform this task more,
you're going to see a,
a decrease in the amount of reaction
time required to complete the task.
Great.
We've learned two things about humans.
Let's add some more in.
So,
uh,
for those who might've done some
reinforcement learning,
the learning is one of those approaches,
a temporal difference learning that's
had some evidence of similar sorts of
processes and the dopamine centers of
the brain.
And it basically says in a sequential
learning task,
you perform the task,
you get some sort of reward.
How are you going to kind of update your
representation of what to do in the
future,
such as to maximize expectation of
future reward.
And there are various models of how that
changes over time.
And you can build up functions that
allow you to form better and better and
better given trial and error.
Great.
So we've learned three interesting
models here that hold true over multiple
people,
multiple tasks.
And so my question is,
if we take these together and add them
together,
uh,
how do we start to understand a task as
quote unquote simple as chess,
which is to say we could ask questions,
how,
how long would it take for a person to
play a,
what mistakes would they make after they
played a few games?
How will they adapt themselves or if we
want to develop system that ended up
being good at chess or at least learning
to become better at chess.
My question is,
if you could,
there doesn't seem to be a clear way to
take these very,
very individual theories and kind of
smash them together and get a reasonable
answer of how to play chess or how do
humans play chess?
And so a gentleman in this slide is
Allan Newell,
one of the founders of ai did incredible
work in psychology and other fields.
Uh,
he gave a series of lectures at Harvard
in 1987 and they were published in 1990
called the unified theories of
cognition.
And his argument to the psychology
community at that point was the argument
on the prior slide.
They had many individual studies,
many individual results,
and so the question was how do you bring
them together to gain this overall
theory,
how do you make forward progress?
And so his proposal was unified theories
of cognition.
She became known as cognitive
architecture,
which is to say,
to bring together your core assumptions,
your core beliefs of what are the fixed
mechanisms and processes that
intelligent agents would use across
tasks.
So the representations,
the learning mechanisms,
um,
the memory systems,
bring them together,
implement them in a theory and use that
across tasks.
And the core idea is that when you
actually have to implement this and see
how it's going to work across different
tasks,
the interconnections between these
different,
uh,
processes and representations would add
constraints and overtime the constraints
would start limiting the design space of
what is necessary and what is possible
in terms of building intelligent
systems.
And so the overall goal from there was
to understand and exhibit a human level
intelligence using these cognitive
architectures.
A natural question to ask is,
okay,
so we've gone from a methodology of
science that we understand how to
operate in a.
We make a hypothesis,
we construct a study,
we gather our data,
we evaluate that data and we false fire.
We do not falsify the original
hypothesis and we can do that over and
over again and we know that we're making
forward progress scientifically.
If I've now taken that model and changed
it into I have a piece of software and
it's representing my theories and to
some extent I can configure that
software in different ways to work on
different tasks.
How do I know that I'm making progress?
And so there's a form of science called
lactose iom and it's kind of shown
pictorially here where you start with
your core of what your beliefs are
about,
uh,
where you're headed,
what is necessary for achieving the goal
that you have.
And around that you'll have kind of
ephemeral hypotheses and assumptions
that over time may grow and shrink.
And so you're trying out different
things,
trying out different things.
And if an assumption is around there
long enough,
it becomes part of that core.
And so as you work on more task and
learn more,
either by your work or by data coming in
from when someone else,
the core is growing larger and larger,
you've got more constraints and you've
made more progress.
And so what I wanted to look at,
where in this community,
uh,
what are some of the core assumptions
that are driving forward scientific
progress.
So one of them actually came out of
those lectures,
they're referred to as noodles,
timescales of human action,
and so off on the left,
the left two columns are both time units
just expressed somewhat differently.
A second from the left being maybe more
useful to a lot of us in understanding
daily life.
Uh,
one step over from there would be kind
of at what level processes are
occurring.
So the lowest three are down at of the
substrate,
the neuronal level.
We're building up to deliberate tasks
that occur in the brain and tasks that
are operating on the order of 10
seconds.
Some of these might occur in the
psychology laboratory,
but probably a step up to minutes and
hours and then above that really becomes
the interactions between agents over
time and so if we start with that,
the things to take away is that a
regular,
the hypothesis is that regularity is
will occur at these different timescales
and that they're useful and so those who
operate at that lowest timescale might
be considering neuroscience,
cognitive,
neuroscience.
When you shift up to the next couple of
levels,
what we would think about in terms of
the areas of science that deal without
would be psychology and cognitive
science and that will shift up a level
and we're talking about sociology and
economics and the interplay between a
agents over time and so what we'll find
with cognitive architecture is that most
of them will tend to sit at the
deliberate act.
We're trying to take knowledge of a
situation and make a single decision and
then sequences of decisions over time.
We'll build to tasks and tasks.
Over time we'll build to more
interesting phenomenon.
I'm actually going to show that that
isn't strictly true,
that there are folks working in this
field that actually do operate one level
below a,
some other assumptions.
So this is a herb Simon receiving the
Nobel prize in economics,
and part of what he received that award
for was an idea of bounded rationality.
So in various fields we tend to model
humans as rational.
Uh,
and his argument was a,
let's consider that human beings are
operating under various kinds of
constraints.
And so to model the rationality with
respect to unbounded by how complex the
problem is that they're working on,
how big is that search space that they
have to conquer cognitive limitations.
So a speed of operations,
amount of memory,
short term as well as longterm,
as well as other aspects of our
computing infrastructure that are going
to keep us from being able to
arbitrarily solve complex problems as
well as how much time is available to
make that decision.
And so,
uh,
this is actually a phrase that came out
of his speech when he received the Nobel
prize.
Decision makers can satisfy ice either
by finding optimum solutions for a
simplified world,
which is to say,
take your big problem,
simplify in some way,
and then solve that or by finding
satisfactory solutions for a more
realistic world,
take the world and all its complexity,
take the problem in all its complexity
and try to find something that works.
Neither approach in general dominates
the other and both have continued to
coexist.
And so what you're actually going to see
a throughout the cognitive architecture
community is this understanding that
some problems you're not gonna be able
to get an optimal solution to,
if you consider,
for instance,
a bounded amount of computation,
bounded time,
the need to be reactive to a changing
environment,
these sorts of issues.
And so in some sense,
we can decompose problems that come up
over and over again into simpler
problems,
solve those,
uh,
near optimally or optimally fix those
in,
optimize those,
but more general problems.
We might have to satisfy some.
There's also the idea of the symbol
system hypothesis.
So this is a Allen Newell and Herb Simon
there,
uh,
considering how a computer could play
the game of chess.
So the fiscal system,
physical symbol system talks about the
idea of taking something,
some signal abstractly referred to as
symbol,
combining them in some ways to form
expressions and then having operations
that produced new expressions.
I'm a weak interpretation of the idea
that symbol systems are necessary and
sufficient for intelligent systems.
A very weak way of talking about it is
the claim that there's nothing unique
about the neuronal infrastructure that
we have,
but if we got to the software right,
we could implement it in the bits bytes,
ram and processor that makeup modern
computers.
That's kind of the weakest way to look
at this.
That we can do it with silicon and not
carbon.
I'm stronger way that this used to be
looked at was more of a logical
standpoint,
which is to say if we can encode a rules
of logic,
these tend to line up if we think
intuitively have a planning and problem
solving.
And if we can just get that right and
get enough fats in there and enough
rules in there that somehow
intelligence,
uh,
well,
that's what we need for intelligence and
eventually we can get to the point of
intelligence and that's what you need
for intelligence.
And that was a,
a starting point that lasted for awhile.
I think by now,
most folks in this field would agree
that that's necessary to be able to
operate logically,
but that there are going to be
representations and processes that'll
benefit from non symbolic
representations.
So particularly perceptual processing,
visual auditory and processing things in
a more kind of standard machine learning
sort of way.
Uh,
uh,
as well as kind of statistic taking
advantage of statistical rep a
representations.
So we're getting closer to actually
looking at cognitive architectures.
Uh,
I did want to go back to the idea that
different researchers are coming with
different research Fokai Fossa.
Uh,
and we'll start off with kind of the
lowest level and understanding
biological modeling.
So libra and spawn both try to model
different degrees of low level details,
parameters,
firing rates,
connectivities between different kind of
levels of neuronal representations.
They build that up and then they tried
to build tasks above that layer,
but always being very cautious about
being true to a human biological
processes.
At a layer above,
there would be psychological modeling,
which is to say trying to build systems
that are true in some sense to,
uh,
areas of the brain interactions in the
brain and being able to predict a errors
that we made,
a timing that we produced by the human
mind.
And so they're all talk a little bit
about act are his final level down here.
These are systems that are focused
mainly on producing functional systems
that exhibit really cool artifacts and
solve really cool problems.
And so I'll spend most of the time
talking about soar,
but I wanted to point out a relative
newcomer in the game called sigma.
So to talk about spawn a little bit.
We'll see if the sound works in here.
I'm going to let the creator take this
one
or not see how the AB system likes this.
There we go.
Why do you pick the license and the
director of the Center for Science at
the University of philosophy and the
philosophy is considered a general
conceptual issues is any breakdown
equations very concise.
We can like building actual models
recently it's called the small sign
because she wouldn't have million
individual neurons and the model isn't
it and the movement,
so essentially see images and numbers
and in the case of just gotten into that
seat,
reproduce the south and it's looking at.
So for instance,
we all know that we have that show up
and we can simulate a potential area.
Hold on.
I'm working on agents that are extremely
good at one task for instance.
What's special is that pass and this
adds the additional kind of coordinate
the flow of information,
food,
different parts of the model,
something
so provide a pointer at the end.
He's got a really cool book called how
to build a brain and if you google you
can google spawn.
You can find a toolkit where you can
kind of construct circuits that will
approximate functions that you're
interested in,
connect them together,
a set certain properties that you would
want at a low level and build them up
and actually work on tasks at the level
of vision and robotic actuation.
So that's a really cool system as we
move into architectures that are sitting
above that biological level.
I wanted to give you kind of an overall
sense of what they're going to look
like,
what a prototypical architecture is
going to look like.
So they're going to have some ability to
have perception.
Uh,
the modalities typically are more
digital symbolic,
but,
uh,
they will,
depending on the architecture,
be able to handle vision,
audition a and various sensory inputs.
These little gadgets represented in some
sort of short term memory.
Whatever the state's representation for
the particular system is there.
It's typical to have a representation of
the knowledge of what tasks can be
performed when they should be performed,
how they should be controlled.
And so these are typically both actions
that take place internally that manage
the internal state of the system and
perform internal computations,
but also about external actuation and
external might be a digital system,
a game ai,
but it might also be some sort of
robotic actuation and real world.
Uh,
there's typically some sort of mechanism
by which to select from the available
actions in a particular situation.
There's typically some way to augment
this procedural information,
which is to say learn about new actions
possibly modify existing ones.
There's typically some semblance of
what's called a declarative memory.
So whereas procedural,
at least in humans,
uh,
if I asked you to describe how to ride a
bike a,
you might be able to say,
get on the seats and pedal.
But in terms of keeping your balance
there,
you'd have a pretty hard time describing
it declaratively.
So that's kind of the procedural side,
the implicit representation of
knowledge.
Whereas declarative would include facts,
geography,
math,
uh,
but it calls to include experiences that
the hns had a more episodic
representation of declarative memory.
And they'll typically have some way of,
of learning this information.
Augmenting it over time and then finally
some way of taking actions in the world
and they'll all have some sort of cycle
which is perception comes in knowledge
that the agent has is brought to bear on
that.
An action is selected.
Knowledge that knows to condition on
that action will act accordingly,
both with internal processes as well as
eventually to take action and then rinse
and repeat.
Um,
so when we talk about an AI system and
agent in this context,
that would be the fixed representation,
which is whatever architecture we're
talking about plus set of knowledge that
is typically specific to the task button
might be more general.
So oftentimes these systems could
incorporate a more general knowledge
base of facts,
of linguistic facts,
of a geographic facts.
Let's take wikipedia and let's just
stick it in the brain of the system.
There'll be more task general,
but then also whatever it is that you're
doing right now,
how should you proceed in that?
And then it's typical to see this
processing cycle.
And going back to the prior assumption,
the idea is that,
uh,
these primitive cycles allow for the
agent to be reactive to its environment.
So if new things come into his react to,
if the lions sitting over there,
I better run and maybe not do my
calculus homework,
right?
So as long as this cycle is going,
I'm reactive.
But at the same time,
if multiple actions are taken over time,
I'm able to get complex behavior,
uh,
over the longterm.
So this is the act are cognitive
architecture.
Uh,
it has many of the kind of core pieces
that I talked about before.
Let's see if the,
some mouse,
yes,
as useful up there.
So we have the procedural model here.
A short term memory is going to be these
buffers that are on the outside,
uh,
the procedural memory is encoded as what
it called production rules,
or if then rules,
if this is the state of my short term
memory,
this is what I think should happen as a
result,
uh,
you have a selection of the appropriate
rule to fire and an execution.
You're seeing a associated parts of the
brain being represented here,
cool thing that has been done over time
in the act.
Our community is to,
uh,
make predictions about brain areas and
then perform a Mris and,
and gather that data and correlate that
data.
So when you use the system,
you will get predictions about things
like timing of operations,
errors that will occur,
probabilities that something is learned,
but you'll also get predictions about a
to the degree that they can kind of
brain areas that are going to light a
light up a and if you want to,
that's actively being developed at
Carnegie Mellon.
To the left is John Anderson who
developed this cognitive architecture.
Oh,
30 ish years ago.
Uh,
and until the last,
about five years,
he was the primary researcher developer
behind it with Christian.
And then recently he's decided to spend
more time on a cognitive tutoring
systems.
And so Christian has become the primary
developer.
There is a annual act.
Our workshop,
there's a summer school which if you're
thinking about modeling a particular
task,
you can kind of bring your task to them,
bring your data.
They teach you how to use the system and
try to get that study going right there
on the spot,
uh,
to give you a sense of what kinds of
tasks this could be applied to.
So,
uh,
this is a representative of a certain
class of task.
Certainly not the only one.
Let's try this again.
Think powerpoint is going to want a
restart every time.
Okay.
So,
uh,
we're getting predictions about
basically where the eye is going to
move.
What you're not seeing is it's actually
processing things like text and colors
and making predictions about what to do
and how to represent information and how
to process the graph as a whole.
Uh,
I had alluded to this earlier.
There's work by Bonnie John,
a very similar,
so making predictions about how humans
would use computer interfaces.
And at the time she got hired away by
IBM and so they wanted the ability to
have software that you can put in front
of a software designers and when they
think they have a good interface,
press a button.
This model of human cognition with tried
to perform the tasks that had been told
to do and make predictions about how
long it would take.
And so you can have this tight feedback
loop from designer saying,
here's how good your particular,
uh,
interfaces so act are as a whole.
It's very prevalent in this community.
I went to their webpage and counted up
just the papers that they knew about.
It was over 1100 papers over time.
Uh,
if you're interested in it,
the main distribution is in lisp,
but,
uh,
many people have used this and wanting
to apply it to systems that need a
little more processing power.
Uh,
so there's,
the NRL has a java part of it that they
use in robotics.
The air force research lab in Dayton has
implemented it in Erlangen for parallel
processing of large declarative
knowledge bases.
Uh,
they're trying to do service oriented
architectures with it Kuda because they
want what it has to say.
They don't want to wait around for a tap
to figure that stuff out.
Uh,
so that's,
uh,
the two minutes about act are a sigma as
a relative newcomer.
And it's developed out at the University
of southern California by a man named
Paul Rosenbloom,
and I'll mentioned a couple of minutes
because he was one of the prime
developers have soar at Carnegie Mellon,
uh,
so he knows a lot about how solar works
and he's worked on it over the years.
And I think originally I'm going to
speak for him and he'll probably say I
was wrong.
I think originally it was kind of a
mental exercise of can I reproduce sore
using a uniform substrate?
I'll talk about in a little bit.
Uh,
it's 30 years of research code.
If anybody's dealt with research code,
it's 30 years of C and c plus plus with
dozens of graduate students over time.
It's not pretty at all.
Uh,
and,
and theoretically it's,
it's got these boxes sitting out here.
And so,
uh,
he re implemented the core functionality
of sore all using factor graphs and
message passing algorithms under the
hood.
He got to that point and then said
there's nothing stopping me from going
further.
And so now it can do all sorts of modern
machine learning,
vision optimization,
sort of things that would take some time
in any other architecture to be able to
integrate well.
So,
uh,
it's been an interesting experience.
Uh,
it's now going to be the basis for the
virtual human project out at the
institute for creative technology.
It's a institute associated with the
University of southern California for,
until recently could get your hands on
it,
but in the last couple of years he's
done some tutorials on it.
He's got a public release with
documentation.
So that's something interesting to keep
an eye on what I'm going to spend all
the remaining time on the sore cognitive
architecture.
And so you see,
it looks quite a bit like the
prototypical architecture.
And I'll,
I'll give you a sentence again about how
this all operates.
Give a sense of the people involved.
Uh,
we already talked about Alan Newell.
So both John Laird,
who is my advisor and Paul Rosenbloom
were students of Allan Newell.
Uh,
John's thesis project was related to the
chunking mechanism and soar,
which learns new rules based upon
subgoal reasoning.
Uh,
so he finished that,
I believe the year I was born,
and so he's one of the few researchers
you'll find who still actively working
on their thesis project,
uh,
beyond that,
about I think about 10 years ago.
He,
it.
So our technology,
which is company up in Ann Arbor,
Michigan a while it was called soar
technology,
it doesn't do exclusively sore,
but that's a part of the portfolio,
a general intelligence system stuff,
a lot of defense association.
So,
uh,
some notes of what's going to make sore
different from the other architectures
that fall into this kind of functional
architecture category.
Uh,
a big thing is a focus on efficiency.
So John wants to be able to run sore on
just about anything.
We just got on the mailing list,
a desire to run it on a real time
processor and our answer,
while we had never done it before,
it was probably,
it'll work,
uh,
every release,
there's timing tests and we always,
what we,
what we look at is in a bunch of
different domains for a bunch of
different reasons that relate to human
processing.
There's this magic number that comes out
which is 50 milliseconds,
which is to say in terms of responding
to tasks,
if you're above that time,
uh,
humans will sense a delay and you don't
want that to happen.
Now,
if we're working in a robotics task,
50 milliseconds,
if you're dramatically above that,
you just fell off the curb or worse or
you just hit somebody in a car.
Right?
So we're,
we're trying to keep that as low as
possible and for most agents it,
it doesn't even register.
It's below one millisecond fractions of
a millisecond.
But I'll come back to this because a lot
of the work that I was doing was
computer science,
Ai,
uh,
and,
and a lot of efficient algorithms and
data structures and 50 milliseconds was
that very high upper bound.
It's also one of the projects that has a
public distribution.
You can get it in all sorts of operating
systems.
We use something called Swig that allows
you to interface with it and a bunch of
different languages.
We kind of described the Meta
description and you are able to
basically generate bindings and a bunch
of different platforms.
A core of plus,
plus there was a team at soar attack
that said we don't like c Plus,
plus it gets messy,
so they actually did a port over to pure
Java in case that appeals to you.
There's an annual workshop that takes
place in anarbor.
Typically it's free.
You can go there and get a sore tutorial
and talked to folks who are working on
sore and it's fun.
I've been there every year,
but wine in the last decade.
It's just fun to see the people around
the world better using the system and
all sorts of interesting ways to give
you a sense of the diversity of the
applications.
One of the first was our one store,
which was back in the days when it was
an actual challenge to build a computer,
which is to say that your choice of
certain components would have radical
implications for other parts of the
computer,
so it wasn't just the Dell website where
you just,
I want this much ram,
I want this much cpu.
There was a lot of thinking that went
behind it and then physical Labor that
went to construct your computer and so
it was making that process a lot better.
There are folks that apply it to natural
language processing.
A source seven was the core of the
virtual humans project for a long time.
Hci Tasks,
TAC air soar was one of the largest rule
based systems,
tens of thousands of rules over 48
hours.
It was a very large scale simulation,
a defense simulation,
lots of games it's been applied to for
various reasons.
And then in the last few years putting
it onto mobile robotics platforms.
This is Edwin Olson's.
A splinter bought an early version of it
that went on to win the magic
competition.
Uh,
then I went onto put sore on the web and
if after this talk,
you're really interested in a dice game
that I'm going to talk about what you
can actually go to the ios app store and
download.
It's called Michigan Liar's dice.
It's free.
You don't have to pay for it,
but you can actually play a liar's dice
with soar and it's.
You can set the difficulty level.
It's pretty good.
It beats me on a regular basis.
I wanted to give you a couple other just
kind of really weird feeling sort of
applications and really cool
applications.
The first one is out of Georgia tech.
Go powerpoint.
Yes.
Interactive art installation in which
you can engage in collaborative
movement,
improvisation with each other and
virtual dance partners.
This actually creates a hybrid space in
which virtual and corporate real bodies
meet for human and nonhuman is blurred
staring contest as to examine their
relationship with technology.
Installation ultimately examines how
humans and machine can cocreate
experiences in a playful environment.
It creates a social space that
encourages human interaction and
collected dance experiences,
allowing them to send this to creatively
explore movement while having fun.
The development
and I had been a hybrid exploration and
art forms of theater and dance as well
as research and artificial intelligence
and cognitive science.
Moving on.
Inspiration from the ancient art form,
a shadow here,
the original two dimensional version of
the installation.
Let us the conceptualization of the dome
and the liminal space when human
silhouettes and virtual characters
meaning dance together on the projection
surface,
rather than rely on preoperative library
of responses,
the virtual dancer learns his partner
and utilize new theories and
systematically reason about them in
order to choose under response.
The points theory is based in dance and
theater and performance along the
dimension,
the tempo reputation,
kinesthetic response,
shape station relationships,
gesture architecture,
and your topic.
Be Virtual.
Dancer is able to use several different
strategies to respond to human rights.
These include transformation and he
mentions for calling it similar or
complimentary movement from memory in
terms of viewpoints,
admissions and apply action response
patterns that the Asian consumer.
This is part of a larger effort from
setting the relationship between
communication,
cognition and creativity where a large
amount of our efforts go into
understanding human creativity and how
we make things together.
Our work together as a way to understand
how we can build cocreative ai that
serves the same purpose where it could
be a colleague and collaborator with us
and create things with us.
Uh,
so brian was a graduate student in John
Lyric lab as well.
Uh,
before I start this,
I alluded to this earlier where we're
getting closer to rosie saying,
can you teach me?
So let me give you some introduction to
this.
In the lower left,
you're seeing the view of a connect
camera onto a flat surface.
There's a,
a robotic arm,
mainly three d printed parts,
few Servos,
uh,
above that.
You're seeing an interpretation of the
scene a,
we're giving it a kind of associations
of the four areas with semantic titles
like,
uh,
one is the table,
one is the garbage,
just just semantic terms for areas.
But other than that,
the agent doesn't actually know all that
much and it's going to operate in two
modalities.
One is,
we'll call it natural language,
natural language,
a restricted subset of English as well
as some quote unquote pointing.
So you're going to see some mouse
pointers in the upper left saying,
I'm talking about this.
Uh,
and this is just a way to indicate
location.
And so starting off we're going to say
things like,
you know,
pick up the blue block and it's going to
be like,
I don't know what blue is,
what is blue?
And we say,
oh,
well that's a color.
Okay.
Uh,
you know,
so go get the green thing.
What's green?
Oh,
it's a color.
Okay.
Uh,
move the blue thing to a particular
location.
Where's that point at?
Okay,
what is moving like really it has to
start from the beginning and it's
described and it said,
okay,
now you finished.
And once we got to that point,
now I can say move the green thing over
here.
And it's got everything that it needs to
be able to then reproduce the task given
a new parameters.
And it's learned that ability.
So let me give it a little bit of time.
Oh,
uh,
so you can look a little bit at top left
in terms of the pointers.
You're going to see some text commands
being entered.
So what kind of attributes is blue?
We're going to say it's a color.
And so that can map it then to a
particular sensory modality.
This is green.
So the pointing what kind of thing is
green,
okay,
color.
So now it knows how to understand blue
and green as colors with respect to the
visual scene.
Um,
move rectangle to the table.
Uh,
what is rectangle?
Okay,
now I can map that onto or understanding
parts of the world.
Is this the blue rectangle?
So the arm is actually pointing itself
to get confirmation from the instructor.
Uh,
and then we're trying to understand in
general,
when you say move something,
what is the goal of this operation?
And so then it also has to declare of
representation of the idea of this task,
not only that had completed it,
then it can look back on having
completed the task and understand what
were the steps that lead to achieving a
particular goal.
So in order to move it,
you're gonna have to pick it up.
It knows which one the blue thing is.
Great.
Now put it in the table.
So that's a particular location.
At this point we can say you're done.
You have accomplished the move the blue
rectangle to the table.
And so I can understand what that very
simple kind of processes like and
associate that with the verb to move and
now we can say move the green object or
not doing the garbage and without any
further interaction based on everything
that I've learned up until that point,
it can successfully complete that task.
So this is a work of Shivali Mohan and
others at the soar group at the
University of Michigan on the rosy
project and they were extending this to
playing games and learning the rules of
games through a tech space descriptions
and multimodal experience.
So,
uh,
in order to build up to here's a story.
And so I wanted to give you a sense of
how research occurs in the group.
And so there's these back and forth that
occur over time between,
there's this piece of software called
soar and we want to make this thing
better and give it new capabilities.
And so all our agents are going to
become better.
And we always have to keep in mind,
and you'll see this as I go further,
that it has to be useful to a wide
variety of agents.
It has to be task independent and it has
to be efficient for us to do anything in
the architecture.
All of those have to hold true,
so we do something cool in the
architecture and they,
we say,
okay,
let's solve a cool problem.
So let's build some agents to do this.
And so this ends up testing what are the
limitations,
what are the issues that arise,
uh,
in a particular mechanism as well as
integration with others.
Uh,
and we get to solve interesting
problems.
We usually find there was something
missing and then we can go back to the
architecture and rinse and repeat.
Just to give you an idea again how sore
works.
So the working memory is actually a
directed connected graph.
The perception is just a subset of that
graph.
And so there's going to be symbolic
representations of most of the world.
There is a visual subsystem in which you
can provide a scene graph.
I'm just not showing it here.
Uh,
actions are also a subset of that graph.
And so,
uh,
the procedural knowledge,
which is also production rules can
modify.
It can read sections of the input,
modify sections of the output as well as
arbitrary parts of the graph to take
actions.
So the decision procedure says,
of all the things that I know to do and
I've kind of ranked them according to
various preferences,
what single thing should I do?
A semantic memory for facts.
There's episodic memory.
The agent is always actually storing
every experience it's ever had over time
and episodic memory and it has the
ability to get back to that.
And so the similar cycle we saw before
we get input in the perception called
the input link rules are going to fire
all in parallel and say,
here's everything I know about this
situation.
Here's all the things I could do.
Decision Procedure says,
here's what we're going to do based on
the selected operator.
All sorts of things could happen with
respect to memories providing input,
a rules firing to perform computations,
and as well as potentially output in the
world.
Uh,
I don't remember.
Agent reactivity is required.
We want the system to be able to react
to things in the world at a very quick
pace.
So anything that happens in this cycle
at Max,
the overall cycle has to be under 50
milliseconds.
So that's gonna be a constraint we hold
ourselves to.
And so the story I'll be telling will
say how we got to a point where we
started actually forgetting things and
we're an architecture that doesn't want
to be like humans.
We want to create cool systems,
but what we realized was something that
we do,
there's probably some benefit to it and
we actually put it into our system and
the lead to good outputs.
So here's the research path.
I'm going to walk down a.
We had a just a simple problem which was
we have these memory systems and
sometimes they're going to get a queue
that could relate to multiple memories.
And the question is if you have a fixed
mechanism,
what should you return in a task
independent way?
Which one of these many,
many memories shitty return.
That was our question and we look to
some human data on this.
Something called the rational analysis
of memory done by John Anderson and
realized that in human language,
their recency and frequency effects that
maybe it would be useful.
And so,
uh,
we actually did an analysis found that
not only does this occur but it's useful
in what are called word sense
disambiguation tasks.
And I'll get to that what that means in
a second.
Develop some algorithms to scale this
really well and it turned out to work
out well not only in the original task
but we look to,
to other completely different ones.
The same underlying mechanism ended up
producing some really interesting
outputs.
Suddenly talking about word sense
disambiguation real quick.
So as a core problem in natural language
processing,
if you haven't heard of it before,
let's say we have an agent and for some
reason it needs to understand the verb
to run looks to its memory and finds
that it could,
you know,
run in the park.
It could be running a fever,
could run an election that could run a
program.
And the question is,
what should an task,
independent memory mechanism return if
all you've been given is the verb to
run?
And so the rational analysis of memory
look through multiple texts Corpora,
and what they found was if a particular
word had been used recently,
it's very likely to be reused again.
And if it hadn't been used recently,
there's going to be this effect to
where,
uh,
the expression here,
the t is time since the most recent use.
It's going to some those with a
exponential decay.
So what it looks like if time is going
to the right,
a activation higher is better.
As you get these individual usages,
you get these little drops and then
venture he dropped down.
And so if we had just one usage of a
word,
the red would be what the decay would
look like.
And so the core problem here is if we're
at a particular point and we want to
select between kind of the blue thing or
the red thing,
blue would have a higher activation.
And so maybe that's useful.
This is how things are modeled with
human memory,
but is it useful in general for tasks?
And so we looked at common corpora used
in word sense distribuition and just
said,
well,
if we just look at this corporate twice
and we just use answers,
prior answers,
you know,
I asked the question,
what is the sense of this word?
I took a guess,
I got the right answer and I used that
recency and frequency information to my
task.
Independent memory.
Would that be useful?
And somewhat of a surprise,
but somewhat maybe not have a surprise.
It actually performed really well across
multiple corporate.
So we said,
okay,
this seems like a reasonable mechanism.
Let's look at implementing this
efficiently and the architecture.
And the problem was this term right here
said,
for every memory,
for every time step you're having to k
everything.
That doesn't sound like a recipe for
efficiency if you're talking about lots
and lots of knowledge over long periods
of time.
So we,
uh,
made use of a nice approximation that
Petrofac come up with to approximate
tail effect.
So,
uh,
access to that happened long,
long ago.
We could basically approximate their
effect on the overall sum.
So we had a fixed set of values,
uh,
and what we basically said is,
since these are always decreasing and
all we care about is relative order,
let's just only recompute when someone
gets a new value.
So it's,
it's a guests,
it's a heuristic and approximation,
but we looked at how this worked on the
same set of Corpora and in terms of
query time,
if we made these approximations well
under our 50 millisecond,
the effect on task performance was
negligible.
In fact,
on a couple of these that God's ever so
slightly better in terms of accuracy.
And actually if we looked at the
individual decisions that were being
made,
making these sorts of approximations,
we're leading to a,
up to 90,
sorry,
at least 90 percent of the decisions
being made were identical to having done
the true a full calculation.
So we said this is great and we
implemented this and worked really well.
And then we started working on what
seemed like completely unrelated
problems.
One was in mobile robotics.
We had a mobile robot.
I'll show a picture of in a little
while,
roaming around the halls performing all
sorts of tasks and what we're finding
was if you have a system that's
remembering everything in your short
term memory and your short term memory
gets really,
really big.
I don't know about you.
My short term memory feels really,
really small.
I would love it to be big,
but if you make your memory really big
and you try to remember something,
you're not having to pull lots and lots
and lots of information into your short
term memory.
So the system was actually getting
slower simply because it had a lot of
short term memory,
a representation of the overall map.
It was looking at so large working
memory problem,
Liar's dice game,
you play with dice.
We were doing an rl based system on this
reinforcement learning and it turned out
a really,
really big value function.
Worse having to store lots of data and
we didn't know which stuff we had to
keep around to keep the performance,
uh,
up.
So we had a hypothesis that forgetting
was actually going to be a beneficial
thing that maybe maybe the the problem
we have with our memories that we
really,
really disliked this forgetting thing.
Maybe it's actually useful.
And so we experimented with the
following policy.
We said,
let's forget a memory if one we haven't
really.
It's not predicted to be useful by this
base level activation.
We haven't used it recently,
we haven't used it frequently,
maybe it's not worth it.
That.
And we felt confident that we could
approximately reconstructed if we
absolutely had to.
And if those two things held,
we could forget something.
Uh,
so it's this bay same basic algorithm,
but instead of the ranking them,
it's if we set a threshold for base
level activation finding when it is that
a memory is going to pass that threshold
and try to forget based upon that in a
way that's efficient,
that isn't going to scale really,
really poorly.
So we were able to come up with an
efficient way to implement this using an
approximation that ended up for most
memories to be exactly correct to the
original.
I'm happy to go over details of this if
anybody's interested later,
but it ended up being a fairly close
approximation.
One that as compared to an accurate,
completely accurate search for the value
ended up being somewhere between 15 to
20 times faster.
And so what we looked at our mobile
robot here.
Oh,
sorry,
let me get this back because our little
robots actually going around.
That's the third floor of the computer
science building at the University of
Michigan.
He's going around,
he's building a map and again,
the idea was this map is getting too
big,
so here was the basic idea as the robots
going around,
it's going to need this map information
about rooms.
The color there is describing kind of
the strength of the memory and as it
gets farther and farther away and it
hasn't used part of the map for planning
or other purposes,
basically make a decay away so that by
the time it gets to the bottom,
it's forgotten about the top.
But we had the belief that we could
reconstruct portion that map if
necessary.
And so the hypothesis was this would
take care of our speed problems and so
what we looked at was,
here's our 50 millisecond thresholds.
If we do know,
forgetting whatsoever,
bad things were happening over time.
So just a 3,600
seconds,
this isn't a very long time,
we're passing that threshold.
This is dangerous for the robot.
If we implemented task specific,
basically cleanup rules,
which is really hard to get right,
that basically solved the problem when
we looked at our general forgetting
mechanism that we're using in other
places at an appropriate level of decay.
We were actually better than hand tune
rules.
So this was kind of a surprise when for
us,
uh,
the other task seems totally unrelated.
It's a dice game.
You cover your Dayas,
you make bids about what are under other
people's cups.
This is played in pirates of the
Caribbean when they're on the boat and
the second movie and bidding for lives
of service.
Honestly,
this is a game we love to play in the
University of Michigan lab.
Uh,
and so we're like,
hm,
could soar,
play this?
And so we built a system that could
learn to play this game rather well with
reinforcement learning.
And so the basic idea was in a
particular state of the game store would
have options of actions to perform,
it could construct a estimates of their
associated value,
it would choose one of those,
and depending on the outcome,
something good happened,
you might update that value.
And the big problem was that the size of
the state space,
the number of possible states and
actions just is enormous.
And so memory was blowing up.
And so what we said,
similar sort of hypothesis,
if we decay away,
these estimates that we could probably
reconstruct and we haven't used in
awhile,
are things going to get better?
And so if we don't forget it all,
40,000
games isn't a whole lot when it comes to
reinforcement learning.
We were up at two gigs.
We wanted to put this on an iphone that
wasn't gonna work.
So well there had been prior work that
had used a similar approach.
They were down at four or 500 megs.
The iphone is not going to be happy,
but it'll work.
Uh,
so that,
that gave us some hope and we
implemented our system.
Okay.
We're somewhere in the middle.
We can fit on the iphone.
A very good iphone,
maybe an ipad.
The question was though,
a one.
Efficiency.
Yeah,
we,
we fit under a 50 milliseconds,
but two,
how does the system actually performed
when you start forgetting stuff,
can it learn to play well?
And so y axis here,
you're seeing Qa competency,
you play a thousand games.
How many do you win?
So the bottom here,
500.
That's flipping a coin whether or not
you're going to win a.
If we do know for getting whatsoever,
this is a pretty good system.
Uh,
the prior work,
while keeping the memory low is also
suffering with respect to how well it
was playing the game and kind of cool
was the system that was basically more
than having the memory requirement was
still performing at the level of no
forgetting whatsoever.
So just to bring back why I went through
the story was we had a problem.
We look to our example of human level
ai,
which is humans themselves.
We took an idea,
it turned out to be beneficial,
we found in a efficient implementations
and then found it was useful in other
parts of the architecture and other
tasks that didn't seem to relate
whatsoever.
But if you download sore right now,
you would gain access to all these
mechanisms for whatever task you want it
to perform.
Just to give some sense in the field of
cognitive architecture,
what's some of the open issues are.
I think this is true in a lot of fields
in ai,
but a integration of systems over time.
The goal was they wouldn't have all
these theories and uh,
so you could just kind of build over
time,
particularly when folks are working on
different architectures,
that becomes hard.
Uh,
but also when you have very different
initial starting points,
that can still be an issue.
Transfer learning is an issue we're
building into the space of multimodal
representations,
which is to say not only abstract
symbolic,
but also visual.
Wouldn't it be nice if we had auditory
and other senses,
but building that into memories and
processing is still an open question.
There's folks working on metacognition,
which is to say the agent self-assessing
its own state,
its own processing,
some work has been done in here but
still a lot and I think the last one is
a really important question for anybody
taking this kind of class,
which is what would happen if we did
succeed,
if we did make human level ai and if you
don't know that picture right there is
from a show that I recommend that you
watch a,
it's by the BBC,
it's called humans and it's basically
what if we were able to develop what are
called synths in the show.
I think the,
a robot that can clean up after your
laundry and cook and all that good stuff
interact with you if looks and interacts
as a human but is completely or servant
and then hilarity and complex issues in
sue.
So I highly recommend if you haven't
seen that to go watch that.
Uh,
I think these days there's a lot of
attention play a paid to machine
learning in particular deep learning
methods as well.
It should.
They're doing absolutely amazing things.
Uh,
and often the question is,
well,
you're doing this and there's deep
learning over there,
you know,
how do they compare?
And I honestly don't feel that that's
always a fruitful question because most
of the time they tend to be working on
different problems.
Uh,
if I'm trying to find objects in the
scene,
I'm going to pull out tensor flow.
Uh,
I'm really not going to pull out store.
It doesn't make sense.
It's not the right tool for the job that
haven't been said.
There are times when they tend to work
together really,
really well.
So the rosy system that you saw there,
there was some,
uh,
I believe neural networks being used in
the object recognition mechanisms for
the vision system.
There's td learning going on in terms of
the dice game where we can pick and
choose and use this stuff.
Absolutely great because there are
problems that are best solved by these
methods.
So why avoid it?
Uh,
and then on the other side,
if you're trying to develop a system
where you,
you know,
in different situations,
know exactly what you want the system to
do,
soar or other rule based systems and to
being the right tool for the right job.
So absolutely why not make it a piece of
the overall system?
Uh,
some recommended readings and some
venues.
Uh,
I'd mentioned unified theories of
cognition.
This is Harvard press,
I believe.
Uh,
the cognitive architecture was mit press
came out in 2012.
I'll say I'm coauthor and a
theoretically would get proceeds,
but I've donated them all to the
University of Michigan.
So I can just make this recommendation
free of ethical concerns.
Personally,
it's an interesting bug.
It brings together lots of a history and
lots of new features.
It's if,
if you're really interested in soar,
it's an easy sell.
I had mentioned crystallized Smith's how
to build a brain.
Really cool read,
download the software,
go through tutorials.
It's really great.
How can the human mind and occur in the
physical universe is one of the core
act,
our books.
So it talks through a lot of the
psychological underpinnings and how the
architecture works.
It's,
it's a fascinating read,
uh,
one of the papers trying to remember
what year 2008.
This goes through a lot of different
architectures in the field.
It's 10 years old,
but it gives you a good kind of broad
sweep if you want something a little
more recent.
This is last month's issue of Ai
magazine completely dedicated to
cognitive systems.
Uh,
so it's a good place to look for this
sort of stuff.
In terms of academic venues,
a aaa,
I often has cognitive systems track.
There's a conference called ICCM
international conference on cognitive
modeling,
a where you'll see kind of a span from
biologic all the way up to ai cognitive
science or cog psy.
They have a conference as well as the
journal.
A ACS has a conference as well as an
online journal,
uh,
advances in cognitive systems.
Cognitive Systems Research is a journal
that has a lot of this good stuff.
There's Agi.
The conference,
Becca is biologically inspired cognitive
architectures and I had mentioned both.
There's a sore workshop and enact our
workshop that go on annually,
so leave it at this.
There's some contact information there
and a lot of when I do these days
actually involves kind of explainable
machine learning,
integrating that with cognitive systems
as well as a optimization and robotics
that scales really well and also
integrates with cognitive systems.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Do you have
a question?
Please line up to one of these two
microphones.
So,
uh,
what's the,
what's the main heuristics that you're
using?
I'm in soar that they're gonna be
heuristics at the task level and the
agent level or there's the heuristics
that are built into the architecture to
operate efficiently.
So I'll give you a core example that
comes into the architecture and it's a
fun trick that if you're a programmer
you could use all the time,
which is a only changes which is to say
one of the cool things about [inaudible]
is you can load it up with literally
billions of rules.
And I say literally because we've done
it and we know that it can turn over
still in,
under a millisecond.
And this happens because instead of most
systems which process all the rules,
we just say,
well,
anytime anything changes in the world,
that's what we're going to react to.
And of course if you look at the
biological world,
similar sorts of tricks are being used.
So that's one of the core ones that
actually permeates a multiple of the
mechanisms.
Uh,
when it comes to individual tasks,
it really is task specific,
what that is.
So for instance,
with the liars dice game,
if you were to go and download it,
when you're setting the level of
difficulty of it,
what you're basically selecting is the
subset of sharistics that are being
applied.
And it starts very simply with things
like if I see lots of sixes,
then I'm likely to believe a high number
of six exist.
But if I don't,
they're probably not there at all.
So it's a start.
But any Bayesian wouldn't really buy
that argument.
So then you start tacking on a little
bit of probabilistic calculation and
then attacks on some history of prior
actions of the agents.
So it really just builds now the rosy
system.
One of the cool things they're doing is
game learning and specifically having
the agent be able to accept by a text
like natural text,
a heuristics about how to play the game
even when it's not sure what to do.
Oh,
so you.
At one point you mentioned about
generating new rules.
So I'm wondering like how do you do
that?
So okay,
so I'm.
The first thing that comes to my mind
are local search methods.
Okay.
So
one thing is you can actually implement
heuristic search in rules in the system
and that's actually how the robot
navigates itself.
So it does heuristic search,
but at the level of rules generate new
rules.
That chunking mechanism says the
following,
if it's the case that in order to solve
a problem you had to kind of sub goal
and do some other work and you figure
out how to solve all that work and
you've got a result then,
and I'm greatly oversimplifying,
but if you ever were in the same
situation again,
why don't I just memorize the solution
for that same situation.
So it basically learns over all the sub
processing that was done and encodes the
situation that was in those conditions
and the results that were produced as
action.
And that's the new rule.
Alright,
thank you.
I'm high.
So deep learning and neural networks.
So it looks at it as a bit of an
impedance mismatch between your system
and those types of system because you've
got a fixed kind of memory architecture
and they've got the memory and the wills
all kind of mixed together into one
system.
But could you interface your system or
sort of like system with deep learning
by playing in deep learning agents as
rules in your system.
So it would have to have some local
memory but some reason you can't plug in
deep learning as a kind of a rule like
module.
So I'm going to answer this.
You work on it is has there been any
work on that or.
Yeah,
so I'll answer it at multiple levels.
One is you are writing a system and you
want to use both of these things.
How do you make them talk and there is
an Api that you can interface with any
environment in any set of tools and if
people are earning is one of them.
Great.
And if so is the other one.
Cool.
Do you have no problem and you can do
that today.
And we have done this numerous times in
terms of integration into the
architecture.
All we have to do is think of a sub
problem in which all over simplify this,
but basically function approximation is
useful.
I'm seeing basically kind of the,
a fixed structure of input.
I'm getting feedback as to the output
and I want to learn the mapping to that
over time.
If you can make that case,
then you integrate it as a part of the
module.
Great.
Uh,
and we have learning mechanisms that do
some of that deep learning just hasn't
been used to my knowledge to solve any
of those sub problems.
There's nothing keeping it from being
one of those,
particularly when it comes down to the
low level visual part of things,
a problem that arises.
So I'll say what actually makes some of
this difficult,
uh,
and it's a general problem called symbol
grounding.
So at the level of what most,
what happens mostly in store,
it is symbols being manipulated in a
highly discreet way and so how do you
get yourself from pixels and low level
non symbolic representations to
something that's stable and discreet and
can be manipulated and that is
absolutely an open question in that
community and that will make things
hard.
So spawn actually has an interesting
answer to that and it has a distributed
representation and it operates over
distributed representations in what
might feel like a symbolic way.
So they're kind of ahead of us on that,
but they're,
they're starting from a lower point and
so they've dealt with some of these
issues and they have a pretty good
answer to that and that's how they're
moving up.
And that's also why I showed sigma,
which is at its low level,
it's message passing algorithms.
It's implementing things like a slam and
sat solving and other sorts of really,
really it can implement those on very
low level primitives but higher up it
can also be doing what soar is doing.
So there's an answer there as well.
Okay.
Thank you.
Um,
so another way of doing it would be to
layer the,
um,
the system,
so have a system,
preprocessing the,
the,
the sensory input or post processing and
then draft and the other one,
that'd be another way of combining the
two.
And that's actually what's going on in
the rosy system.
So the detection of objects in the scene
is a Jew just software that somebody
wrote.
I don't believe it's the deep learning
specifically,
but like the color detection out of it I
think is an Svm if I'm correct so easily
could be deep learning.
Thanks.
You mentioned like the importance of
forgetting in order to food memory
issues,
but you said you could only forget
because you could reconstruct and I'm
curious,
how do you,
when you said we can show you each know
that it happened before,
so do you just compress the data?
Like do you really forget it or okay,
so and I put quotes up and I said,
you think you can reconstruct it?
So we came up with approximations of
this and so let me try to answer this
very grounded when it comes to the
mobile robot and you had rooms that you
had been to before the entire map and
its entirety was being constructed in
the robots.
Semantic memory.
So here's facts.
This room is connected to this room
which is connected this room which
connected this room.
So we had those sorts of representations
that existed up in semantic memory.
The rules can only operate down on
anything that's in short term memory.
So basically we were removing things
from the short term memory and as
necessary be able to reconstruct it from
the longterm.
You could end up in some situations in
which you had made a change locally in
short term memory,
didn't get a chance to get it up and it
actually happened to be forgotten a way
so you weren't guaranteed,
but it was good enough that the
connectivity survived.
The agent was able to perform the exact
same task and we gained some benefit for
the RL system.
The rule we came up with was the initial
estimates in the value system,
which is,
here's how good I think that is,
that's based on the heuristics I
described earlier.
Some simple probabilistic calculations
of counting some stuff.
That's where that number came from.
We computer before we could compute it
again.
The only time we can't reconstruct it
completely is if it had seen a certain
number of updates over time.
It's such a large state space.
There are so many actions,
so many states that most of the states
were never being seen.
So most of those could be exactly
reproduced by,
uh,
the agent just thinking about it a
little bit.
And there was only a tiny,
tiny,
I'm going to say under one percent of
the estimate the value system that ever
got updates.
And that's actually not inconsistent
with a lot of these kinds of problems
that have really,
really large state spaces.
So,
uh,
I think the statement was something
like,
if we had ever updated it,
don't forget it.
And you saw that was already reducing
more than half of the memory load.
We could have something higher to say 10
times something like that.
And that would say we could reconstruct
almost all of it.
The prior work that I referenced was
strictly saying if it falls below
threshold,
no matter how many times they ended up
dating,
no matter how much information was
there.
And so when we were adding was probably
can reconstruct and that was getting us
the balance between the efficiency and
the ability to forget.
So just in its infancy,
we can probably,
we can show you state you keep trying to
use generic is the issue needs to be
constructed.
Your will,
you're going to run it again sometime
fly.
If I get back into that situation and I
happen to forget it,
the system knew how to compute it the
first time it goes and looks at all the
hand and just pretends it's in that
situation for the very,
very first time.
Reconstruct that value estimate.
Just a quick question on top of that
again,
question.
Okay.
So the actual mechanism of forgetting is
fascinating.
So lstmrs,
rns have mechanisms for learning what to
forget and whatnot to forget.
Have you,
has there been any exploration of
learning the forgetting process says
doing something complicated or
interesting with which parts to forget
or not?
Uh,
the closest I will say was kind of a
metacognition project that's 10 or 15
years old at this point,
which was what happens when it gets into
a place where it actually knows that it
learned something that's harmful to it,
that's leading to poor decisions.
Uh,
and in that case it was still a very
rule based process,
but it wasn't learning to forget he was
actually learning to override it's prior
knowledge,
which might be closer to some of what we
do when we know we have a bad habit.
We don't have a way of forgetting that
habit,
but instead we can try to learn
something on top of that that leads to
better a operation in the future.
To my knowledge that's the only work,
at least in sore that's been done.
Just find the topic really fascinating.
What lessons do you think we can draw
from the fact that forgetting.
So ultimately you're the action of
forgetting a is driven by the fact that
you want to improve performance,
but do you think for getting is
essential for Agi,
the act of forgetting for building
systems that operate in as well.
How important is forgetting?
I can think of easy answers to that.
So one might be,
if we take the cognitive modeling
approach,
we know humans do forget and we know
regularities of how humans forget.
And so whether or not the system itself
forgets at least has to model the fact
that the humans it's interacting with
are going to forget.
And so at least it has to have that
ability to model in order to interact
effectively because if it assumes we
always remember everything and can't
operate well in that environment,
uh,
I think we're going to have a problem is
true for getting going to be necessary.
That's interesting.
Our,
our agi system is going to hold a grudge
for all eternity.
We might want them to forget this early
age when we were forcing them to work in
our laboratory.
I think I know what you're trying to.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
And how to build such a system.
Yeah,
exactly.
Go ahead.
So I have two quick,
two quick questions.
One is,
would you be able to speculate on how
you can connect function approximators
such as deep down works to symbols.
And the second question is completely
different.
This is regarding your action selection.
I know you didn't speak much about that
when you have different theories in your
knowledge representation and you have an
action selection which has to make
constructive plan by reasoning about the
different theories and the different
pieces of knowledge that are now held
within a,
you know,
your,
your memory or anything like that.
All your rules.
What kind of algorithms to use in the
action selection to come up with a
plant,
you know,
is there any concept of differentiation
of the symbols or you know,
or grammars or admissible grammars and
things like that that you use in action
selection?
I'm actually going to answer the second
question first and then you're going to
have to remind me of what the first one
was.
Uh,
when I,
when I get to the end.
So the action selection mechanism,
one of these core tenants I said is it's
got to get through this cycle fast.
So everything that's really,
really built in has to be really,
really simple.
And so the decision procedure is
actually really,
really simple.
It says the rules are going to fire,
the rules are going,
the production rules are going to fire,
and there's gonna be a subset of them
that will say something like,
here's an operator that you could select
to.
These are of acceptable operator
preferences.
There are ones are gonna say,
well,
based upon the fact that you said that
that was acceptable,
I think it's the best thing,
or the worst thing,
or I think 50 50 chance I'm going to get
reward out of this.
There's actually a fixed language of
preferences that are being asserted and
actually a nice fixed procedure by which
if I have a set of preferences to make a
very quick and clean decision.
So what's basically happened is you've
pushed the hard questions of how to make
complex decisions about actions up to a
higher level.
The low level architecture is always
given a set of options going to be able
to make a relatively quick decision and
it gets pushed into the knowledge of the
agent to construct a sequence of
decisions that overtime is going to get
to.
The more interesting questions you're
talking,
but how can you reason that that
sequence will take you to the goal that
you desire?
So
is there any guarantee on that?
Is that.
Yeah.
Uh,
in general across tasks.
No,
but people have,
for instance,
implemented a star I was mentioning as
rules,
right?
Yeah.
So I know given certain properties about
the search task,
that task that's being searched based
upon these rules,
given a finite search space,
eventually it will get there.
And if I have a good heuristic in there,
I know certain properties about the
optimality.
So I can reason at that level.
In general,
I think this comes back to the
assumption I made earlier about bounded
rationality to say parts of the
architecture or solving sub-problems
optimally.
The general problems that it's going to
work on.
It's going to try its best based upon
the knowledge that it has.
And that's about the end of guarantees
that you can typically make any
architecture.
Okay.
I think your first question was
speculate on connecting symbol,
a product function approximators a
multiple layer function approximators
like deep learning networks to do
symbols that you can reason about at a
higher level.
Yeah,
I think that's a great open space.
If I had time,
this will be somebody I'll be working on
right now,
which is somewhere before I basically
said taking a scene and then detecting
objects out of that scene and using
those as simple as and reading about
those over time.
I think the spawn work is quite
interesting.
So
the symbols that they're operating on
are actually,
uh,
a distributed representation of the
input space.
And the closest I can get to this is if
you've seen a word tobacco where you're
taking a language corpus and what you're
getting out of there as a vector of
numbers that has certain properties,
but it's also a vector that you could
operate on as a unit.
So it has nice properties.
You can operate with it on other
vectors.
You know that if I got the same word in
the same context,
I would get back to that exact same
vector,
so those are the kind of representation
that seems like it's going to be able to
bridge that chasm where we can get from
sensory information to something that
can be operated on and reasoned about in
this sort of symbolic architecture and
get us from there.
From actual sensory information.
I had a question.
What do you think are the biggest
strengths of the cognitive architecture
approach compared to other approaches in
artificial intelligence?
And the flip side of that,
what do you think are the biggest
shortcomings of cognitive architecture
with respect to us
actually you being humans,
human level,
like like what needs to be like?
How come cognitive architecture has not
solved agi because we want job security.
That's the answer.
We've totally solved it already.
So strength I think conceptually is
keeping an eye on the ball,
which is if what you're looking at is
trying to make human level ai
I.
it's hard.
It's challenging.
It's ambitious to say that's the goal
because for decades we haven't done it.
It's extraordinarily hard.
It,
it is less difficult in some ways to
constrain yourself down to a single
problem that hadn't been said.
I'm not very good at making a car drive
itself.
In some ways that's a simpler problem.
It's great at challenging and of itself
and it will have great impact on
humanity.
It's a great problem to work on.
Human level.
Ai is huge.
It's not even well defined as a problem.
And so,
uh,
what,
what's the strength here?
Bravery.
Stupidity in the face of failure,
a resilience over time,
keeping alive.
This idea of trying to reproduce a level
of human intelligence that's more
general.
I don't know if that's a very
satisfactory answer for you.
Downside
home runs are fairly rare and by Homerun
I mean a system that finds its way to
the,
the general populace to the marketplace.
I'd mentioned Bonnie John specifically
because you know,
this is 20,
30 years of research and then she found
a way that actually makes a whole lot of
sense under direct application.
So it was a lot,
a lot of years of basic research,
a lot of researchers.
And then there was,
there was a big win,
there was this one,
oh,
this was a Bonnie,
John was a researcher,
or this was using act,
our models of eye gaze and reaction and
so forth to be able to make predictions
about how humans would use a user
interfaces.
So those sorts of outcomes are rare.
It if you work in ai,
one of the first things you learn about
his blocks world,
it's kind of in the classic Ai Textbook.
I will tell you I've worked on that
problem in about three different
variants.
I've gone to many conferences where
presentations have been made about
blocks world,
which is to say we're good.
Progress is being made,
but the way you end up thinking about is
in really,
really small constrained problems.
Ironically you have this big vision,
but in order to make progress,
that ends up being on moving blocks on a
table.
And so it's.
It's a big challenge.
I just think it'll take a lot of time.
The I'll say the other thing they
haven't,
we haven't really gotten too.
Although I brought up spawn and I
brought up a sigma,
an idea of how scale this thing,
something I like about deep learning is
to some extent with lots of asterisks
and 10,000
foot view,
it's kind of like,
well,
we've gotten this far.
All right,
let's just provide a different inputs,
different outputs,
and we'll have some tricks on the middle
and suddenly you have end to end deep
learning,
but a bigger problem and a bigger
problem there.
There's a way to see how this expands
given enough data,
given her enough computing and
incremental advances.
When it comes to sore,
it takes not only a big idea,
but it takes a lot of software
engineering to integrate it.
There's a lot of constraints built into
it.
It,
it slows it down.
So something like sigma is a,
Oh well I can change a little bit of the
configuration of the graph.
I can use variance on the algorithm.
Boom.
It's integrated like an experiment
fairly quickly.
So starting with that sort of
infrastructure does not give you the
constraint.
You kind of want with your big picture
vision of going towards human level ai,
but in terms of being able to be agile
in your research,
it's,
it's kind of incredible.
I see.
Thank you.
A couple more.
You had mentioned that ideas such as
[inaudible] Kate,
these techniques,
they were based on the original
inspirations were based off of a human
cognition and because humans can't
remember everything.
So were there any instances of the other
way round where some discovery in
cognitive bottling fueled it?
Another discovery in cognitive science?
Uh,
so one thing I'm gonna
went out and your question was based
indicated with respect to human
cognition.
The study actually was let's look at
text and properties of text and use that
to then make predictions about what must
be true about human cognition.
So John Anderson and the other
researchers looked at,
I believe it was New York Times
articles,
his own John Anderson's emails,
and I'm trying to remember what the
third,
I think it was parents utterances with
their kids or something like this.
It was actually looking at text corpora
and the words that were occurring in a
varying frequencies that,
that analysis,
that rational analysis actually lead to
models that got integrated within the
act art architecture that then became
validated through multiple trials that
then became validated with respect to
Mri scans and is now being used to both
do study back with humans,
but also develop systems that interact
well with humans.
So I think that in and of itself ends up
being an example to cheat.
But the,
uh,
the UAV,
the sor UAV system,
I believe is a single robot that has a
multi,
multiple agents running on it.
So where is this?
I got it off your website.
Okay.
But either way,
your systems allow for multi agents.
Okay.
Uh,
so my question is how are you preventing
them from converging with new data and
are you changing what they're forgetting
selectively as one of those ways?
So I'll say yes,
you can have multiple source systems on
a single system or multiple systems.
There's not any real strong theory that
relates to multi agent system.
So there's no real constraint there that
you can come up with a protocol for them
interacting.
Each one is going to have its own set of
memories,
set of knowledge.
There really is no constraint on you
being able to communicate like you would
if it were any other system interacting
with sore.
So I don't really think I have a great
answer for it.
Okay.
So that is to say if,
if you had good theories,
good algorithms about how systems work
and how they can bring knowledge
together form of fusion sort of way.
It might be something that you could
bring to a multiagent source system,
but there's nothing really there to help
you.
There's no mechanisms there really to
help you do that any better than you
would otherwise.
And you would have to kind of
constraints on your representations of
processes to what it has fixed in terms
of it's sort of memory and it's sort of
processing cycle.
Okay.
Thank you.